I'll just get the latest on the ground
now I'm joined by military analyst and
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean bellshaw
good to see you again um let's start
shall we with the fact that Ukraine
seemed to be using foreign Fighters we
haven't talked much about this in the
course of the war and we've known it's
been going on but what can you tell us
about you know what Sky News has
discovered yeah well both sides are
using foreign Fighters we've been having
a look at the Georgian Fighters shown on
the left here they're particularly well
motivated they're particularly well
trained they're unified with Ukraine
against a common enemy and once the war
is over they will vacate back home from
a Russian perspective the conscript Army
on the right is not performing uh well
on the battlefield uh Russia's before
therefore leaning more heavily on
mercenary groups like The Wagner group
um it's always mercenaries it's about
their motivation they're not motivation
to serve their country they're motivated
about money and the problem with that is
that if they don't survive they if they
don't survive they can't spend their
money so they're absolutely looking at
self-preservation the violent group's
worth a bit of a study in this because
they are largely the front line of
Russian efforts around the donbass here
you you have Kenny prison who's the
leader of the Wagner group is a
convicted Thief but he's also a close
personal Ally of President Putin as the
Russian Army's performance has not done
well actually in Ukraine then actually
the role of the mercenaries has
increased in value and therefore he then
sees stock has also increased since
building his power base it's there's
rumors that he's actually building some
sort of people's militia on the west end
of Russia Eastern side of the donbass
and it's clear this is going to be
outside Russian normal Commander control
outside the Russian military the
question is what's the agenda and that's
always the worry when you use mercenary
groups you're never quite sure what
they're going to be doing in the future
and both sides need more manpower we've
just heard from Moscow in the last few
minutes that Vladimir Putin saying 50
000 Russians are now serving in combat
units so it's not just about recruiting
Manpower but it's about recruiting
Firepower as well yes you can't just
because you've got soldiers on the
ground you also need to match that with
military equipment and of course with an
enduring War neither side has got enough
equipment in its inventory or its War
stocks so both sides need help at the
moment Ukraine is looking to the West
for high technology support with
ammunition with mortars with guns and
anti-tank weapons but Russia is also
looking for help but he doesn't have
quite that same level of sport lean
towards China potentially but China may
be a natural Ally but doesn't want to be
seen to be supporting Russia in the war
Russia's looked to Iran and they've
provided the Shahid 136 drones they've
also been asked potentially to provide
service to her missiles but the fact
remains that Russia has to be really
careful how low it runs its stocks
because of course it leaves the country
vulnerable to an attack from another
Nation if it runs it too low yeah we've
been talking a lot haven't we over
recent weeks about Russian drone power
and where they're getting those drones
from and their capability to make more
of them themselves but what they really
want is military aircraft yes one of the
things that we haven't reported much
about is the Russian Air Force which has
not been dominant in this fight the
Russians haven't maintained air
superiority over Ukraine as a result of
which Ukraine airspace had incredibly
dangerous place for the Russian Air
Force Ukrainian claims that it shot down
278 Russian military aircraft that
number to put into context is over
double the amount that the Soviets lost
in their Afghan war so it's a huge gap
now none of this can be verified at the
moment so we have to take it with a bit
of pinch of salt but even if it's close
to being true that leaves a massive hole
in Russia's military capability and you
can't knit down to the supermarket to
buy spares of these it takes years to
replace them and the pilots take years
to train so for Russia this is leaving
some pretty large holes that are going
to take a long time to fill for Russia's
Putin okay Sean thank you we'll speak
later on in the program but that's the
update with what's happening in Ukraine